Relationships are terrifying.
I mean, did you know half of all marriages
last forever??
Ello loves, Julian here for DNews.
Alright, first of all the oft quoted statistic
that 50% of marriages fail is just plain wrong.
The actual number for first marriages is closer
to 20-25%, but that still begs the question;
why do they fail?
Why do people who have avowed themselves to
one another for their whole lives not go the
distance?
John and Julie Gottman have been pondering
that question for decades.
By the way, they’re both psychologists,
and yes, they’re married.
Feel free to “d’awwww” now.
According to the Gottmans, you can actually
predict with 94% certainty which relationships
will be healthy and which will be festering
quagmires of misery and stress simply by how
they support each other.
Anyone who’s been in a relationship knows
that sometimes you and your partner’s interests
don’t align.
Maybe you like hockey but they’re not so
hot on it.
Or maybe they like camping and you understandably
think sleeping on the dirty ground in the
woods with no wifi is a terrible way to spend
a vacation.
But when one person tries to share their interests
with their significant other, that’s a big
for emotional support.
How often they get that acknowledgment makes
all the difference.
John Gottman conducted a study where they
invited 130 newlywed couples to what looked
like a bed and breakfast, but was actually
a lab where they could observe the subjects.
He was watching for how often one person would
say something seemingly inconsequential, like,
“hey check out that bird,” or, “I have
the weirdest feeling we’re being watched.”
Gottman called these “bids” for emotional
support, and noted how often their partner
would respond in a meaningful way.
Their findings show that couples stay together
when they show bids of interest or support
9 out of 10 times, while couples who only
support each other a third of the time split
within six years.
Ignoring those bids for support and acceptance
can have an actual physiological effect.
The Gottmans and a team of researchers brought
in newlyweds to interview them.
They were asked some pretty tough questions
on their relationships while electrodes monitored
their heart rates, blood flow, and sweatiness.
while across the board, everyone responded
calmly to the questions, some couples showed
higher heart rates, blood flow, and sweat
production.
In other words, their palms were sweaty, knees
weak, arms are heavy.
They’re nervous, but on the surface they
look calm and ready.
The stress of being in the same room as their
spouse and talking about their relationship
caused their sympathetic nervous system to
kick in and they had a fight-or-flight response.
Those couples were usually divorced within
6 years.
So if you want to have a healthy and less
stressful relationship, it’s important you
both work to actively support each other’s
emotional bids, even if camping is just the
worst.
If you want to learn another trick to keeping
the fire lit, check out Anthony’s explanation
of how texting can ruin a relationship.
What do you think the key is to living happily
ever after?
Tell us your secret in the comments, and I’ll
see you next time on DNews.